Let's talk a little bit about the latest news
just in advance of tonight's debate, uh, in
the democratic primary field because Cory
Booker has ended his presidential campaign.
He's the latest since, I guess, since Marianne
Williamson to drop out.
Cory Booker's campaign never really got going.
Polling 1.8% as of yet, as of yesterday, he
did get all the way up to nearly 6% back in
February.
That's almost a year ago.
Basically just downhill from there with the
occasional spike to 3% the democratic Senator
from New Jersey put out a statement where
he said, quote, it was a difficult decision
to make, but I got in this race to win and
I've always said I wouldn't continue if there
was no longer a path to victory.
Our campaign has reached the point where we
need more money to scale up and continue building
a campaign that can win money we don't have
and money that is harder to raise because
I won't be on the next debate stage.
And because the urgent business of impeachment
will rightly be keeping me in Washington.
So as as Corey Booker points out, he did not
qualify for tonight's debate and he's decided
it's time to call it quits and he's right.
I mean there's, the analysis here does not
need to go too far beyond that.
Looking at the polls more generally, the next
people who should drop are Tom Stier.
At 2.2% tool.
See Gabbert at 2.3% Amy Klobuchar at 2.8%
certainly at this point in time, if you are
below three, you should be out.
Remember you need 15% in primaries to get
any delegates and then you know Andrew Yang
at 3.5% maybe he can justify staying in a
little longer to see if he gets any delegates
out of Iowa.
Michael Bloomberg at 5.8% can justify it.
Uh, if the DNC changes the rules for qualifying
for debates and he gets into debates, he can
certainly justify it.
I saw some people posting on Facebook that
Cory Booker didn't win because of racism without
denying that we are still dealing with racism
in this country.
Cory Booker was not particularly progressive.
He was not particularly good at debating.
He was not particularly inspiring in terms
of policy.
So to say that we're at, not for Booker being
black, he'd be, the nominee seems very flimsy.
Booker's ideas weren't that great.
He wasn't that great at expressing them in
a way that inspired support.
So his campaign went nowhere.
I actually think it's a good thing that Democrats
who can't win the nomination are starting
to exit.
We want diversity of opinion.
We want different people with different ideas.
But when you look back at that 2016 Republican
primary, there were some people who stuck
out the 2016 Republican primary way too long
from day one.
We basically suspected that this would be
a Biden, Bernie Warren race and it is booted.
Judge is trying to stay in, but he's not really
making any progress in the last six weeks.
This is what it seemed like it would be at
the start.
And it's what it is now.
Is that a self fulfilling prophecy?
To some degree.
What I mean by that is did the fact that so
many people believed it would come down to
Biden, Bernie Warren make it so at the exclusion
of other candidates.
It's a possibility.
But again, there's a reason many people believe
that in a lot of the comments about Cory Booker
dropping out, I saw comments like, um, uh,
you know, Andrew Yang is the only person who
can actually beat Trump or tool.
See Gabard is the only person who can actually
beat Trump.
I hope that those folks eventually come around
to whoever is the offense eventual nominee
and help us defeat Donald Trump.
We saw in 2016 what losing by small margins
in a few States leads to, it leads to four
years or maybe even eight years of Donald
Trump, four years or maybe even eight years
of the United States as the laughingstock
of the world and a malignant, neat, malignantly
narcissistic president who can't be trusted
to tell the truth about anything while installing
radical judges all over the place who will
reign hell on the judiciary for decades to
come.
So no matter what you think now when I see
a comment like only yang or tool so you can
win, or even only Biden or Bernie can win,
I hope everybody will come around and help
defeat Donald Trump when we get to November
cause otherwise we're in big problems.
We'll have continuing coverage of this on
the David Pakman show Instagram page
at David Pakman show.
Follow the Instagram page.
Follow me on Instagram at David dot.
Pacman's well